mon nom est mouvante un g12 1
je suis très forte mais deux sports
préférés sont le basket bas et les skis
depuis je suis une jeune fille
passionnée de lecture et des cuisines
mais comme je vis dans une famille où
quatre personnes ont des allergies
alimentaires différents cuisiner un
repas n'est pas toujours facile
réduire la représentation et de vous
familiariser avec les allergies
alimentaires
le saviez vous les allergies
alimentaires ne cesse d'augmenter au
canada on dirait maintenant que cette
invite pour cent des enfants canadiens
auraient des allergies alimentaires mais
seulement 4 à 5 pour ça des adultes
l'allergie alimentaire est plus
fréquente chez les garçons que chez les
filles mais aussi plus fréquente chez la
femme que chez l'homme mais pour cette
greffe art de la population l'allergie
alimentaire représente un véritable défi
je souhaite vous parler des allergies
alimentaires car c'est un sujet qui me
concerne mais la raison majeure et que
je trouve que tout le monde devrait
connaître ce sujet parfaitement mais que
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas une
personne peut avoir des allergies
alimentaires aux lattes et à des
médicaments ou à des piqûres d'insectes
pour ma part je n'ai que des allergies
alimentaires
les voici je suis allergique aux noix
aux arachides au sésame et aux
légumineuses ce qui ne rend pas toujours
la préparation des repas pour ma famille
une tâche pas c'est si jamais je
mangeais un de ces aliments
je pourrais avoir des rougeurs des
influx des démangeaisons des difficultés
respiratoires
un arrêt cardio respiratoire qui
pourrait entraîner la mort donc pour une
petite ces réactions allergiques les
meilleurs moyens sans doute la
prévention la prévention consiste tout
simplement à être informés de nos
énergies pour éviter de faire toute
réaction
mais en cas de réaction allergique
le meilleur moyen de s'en sortir et
lippi tels les vitesses et de
l'adrénaline injecté intramusculaire
dans notre cuisse après l'utilisation de
l'ipn il était important de se rendre
rapidement à l'epita là où un médecin
décidera si on a besoin d'autres
injections ou d'autres traitements
auparavant nous pouvions aussi utiliser
l'allergie la logique était comédienne
mais il était plus pratique car il était
plus petit il rentrait plus facilement
dans une poche et que nous ferions le
doubs injecteurs de son étui une voix
nous expliquer quoi faire de rester
calme
combien de temps maintenir le people
allergiques sur une puce etc
mais il a été retiré du marché car un
des deux dispositif d'injection soit
celui de l'enfant ou celui de l'adulte
n'injecter pas la bonne dose
d'adrénaline
donc cela pouvait être dangereux pour la
personne qu'ils utilisaient nous
pouvions aussi utiliser le bénin vise le
bien harry était un sirop pour les
enfants et une cellule pour les adultes
qui car nous faisions des signes de
réaction allergique se fait la plupart
d'un l'allergie mais maintenant il n'est
plus conseiller par les médecins
car si nous prenons le besnerais et
qu'il ne stoppe pas l'allergie il
diminue l'effet de l'équipe et ce qui
peut être dangereux pour nous il est
tout de même encore sur le marché pour
les allergies saisonnières comme le
pollen et pour les animaux
quand je vois quelqu'un manger quelque
chose que je ne peux pas manger beaucoup
de personnes me demandent comment
j'aimais ça la plupart du temps je
réponds que je me sens bien mais au fond
de moi je ressens la jalousie car moi
aussi j'aimerais éviter des fois je
ressens la colère pour les mêmes raisons
des fois je trouve la solitude tire
peut-être que vous ne le savez pas mais
une personne avec des allergies et
souvent mis sur une autre table pour
manger ou un bout de table pour éviter
qu'elle soit en contact avec ses amis
préfecture j'éprouvais beaucoup la part
car je savais que si j'ai mangé par
exemple une arrachée il pouvait
m'arriver quelque chose mais la forme ta
j'exagérais donc je croyais que si je
voyais en arachide je pouvais mourir il
y a plusieurs conséquences avant des
allergies il y en a des négatifs idées
positives
les voici il faut très bien accepté par
tout ce qui n'est vraiment pas agréable
car l'aquitaine et et gros ils ne
rentrent pas toujours dans une poche il
faut lire les ingrédients de tout ce
qu'on pense y est surtout pour les
produits esthétiques comme le maquillage
le savon le shampoing et cetera mais
bien sûr pour les aliments surtout ceux
qui sont déjà cuisiné pour nous est prêt
à être consommé comme des biscuits
nous faisons beaucoup moins de sorties
au restaurant car peu de restaurants
offrent la liste complète des
ingrédients qu'ils mettent dans leurs
repas et parmi ceux ci il n'y en a pas
beaucoup que nous pourrions manger
seulement un repas parfois nous devions
même si les recettes car dans la recette
il y à un ingrédient qu'on ne peut pas
changer maintenant les conséquences
positives
j'en ai trouvé quelques-unes malgré que
vous pouvez penser qu'il n'y en a pas
nous devons faire toujours votre maison
même s'ils sont moins diversifiée la
plupart du temps ils sont meilleurs et
plus sain mais surtout une personne avec
des allergies et beaucoup mieux
renseignés sur coiffard quand quelqu'un
fait des allergies même si ce n'est pas
nous donc nous sommes souvent moins
stressés et nous sommes plus capables de
réagir
tout le monde a des conditions de vie
particulières il ne s'agit qu'à
apprendre à vivre avec garder ça en tête
et je sais que tout le monde ici est
capable regardez moi quand j'étais petit
je détestais avoir d allergie
alimentaire maintenant sa mine ça ne me
dérange plus je trouve des trucs et même
des avantages dont garder en tête vous
êtes capable de le faire
merci